put out all the content
i have a thought i make it got it people
demonize quality
people demonize quantity when it is the
singular
unlock of an internet infrastructure
got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
hey gary how are you
it sounds like these guys have had a um
a very uh
fruitful experience already they had a
conversation with simon sinek
that's awesome yeah that's awesome
well hello everybody hope everybody's
well
we've got a whole bunch of folks coming
in and feel free to we know this is
lunch time so
uh don't be jim already set the tone
that if you want to
grab a little something feel free
and and for the group it was gary's
birthday on sunday right saturday thank
you
saturday so gary a belated
happy birthday thank you so much one of
the many things that we love about gary
is that he loves his birthday
there aren't a lot of people that sell
you know that get us get that excited
but we love we love that about him
i heard a great uh steve martin was
talking he's doing some cartoons now
and one of the cartoons is a baby being
born
and the baby the little bubble is best
birthday
ever your first one
that's so good that's so good
so we know we still have so we we're at
30 and i think we've still got a few
more that are
uh who that are coming in but i'm
wondering if we don't maybe get things
um started if that's okay sid
that's great perfect fantastic so really
excited i'm
andrea sullivan the cmo of vaynerx we're
thrilled to be here today to
have a have an interactive session with
all of you
and talk a little bit more about
marketing for the now and and
what it takes to really accelerate
growth and we're lucky to have gary here
to spark the the conversation um we know
that there's a lot of you on the call
today we typically have people go around
and do introductions and share
different challenges and things like
that we want to make sure that you get
the most out of the
the session today and get a tremendous
amount of value uh so we're wondering if
folks do want to use the chat function
um we'll be using that kind of
throughout and and would love for
um for all of you to share different
challenges or opportunities that
that you're thinking about you know as
you're looking into 2021
and that will help us to make sure that
we're you know dialing in
to the the the kind of key areas that
might be most fruitful
for you and your individual businesses
um
so uh with that i'm gonna um
hand it over to you gary in part because
my new puppy
is eating everything in my bedroom so
i'm gonna
pick him up and throw him out the door
if you don't mind and i'll be back in
one second
andrea real quick before you leave am i
doing an opening kind of statement and
are we just going hardcore q
a yeah that's exactly right so wondering
if you can yeah kind of set the tone
um share a little bit about what you're
seeing right now um and then we'll start
jumping into the the dialogue
uh team hi everybody uh the reason i was
asking about that format is
i i really want to get into the details
because what i'm seeing
i don't think is extraordinarily
difficult to
um understand but unfortunately
remarkably hard for most organizations
to execute
and i think that goes into hr and human
dynamics
more than the information of what i mean
by that
everyone is it's extremely clear
to those who are very narrow
and they're paying attention of how
money is spent to make something happen
what's going on and what i mean money is
spent to something happen
i mean spending money on media
amplification or spending money on
pictures videos written words
audio content creative to make something
happen
whether that is to raise money for a
non-profit
early this year i don't know if this hit
anybody's radar but i teamed up with
michael rubin
the founder of fanatics and as soon as
covet hit we created something called
the
all-in challenge where you could get a
role in a robert de niro movie or play
golf with
you know it got a ton of i mean but we
raised 68 million dollars
and we did it because not only did we
have star power but everybody had star
powers sotheby's
it was unlimited things going on as i'm
sure everyone knows we understood how to
make pictures videos and written words
audio sounds and how to amplify them on
the internet
and then when i say the internet youtube
facebook instagram linkedin
you know whatever anyone wants to call
it i think that
something and i look around the room
here and i'm looking at the faces and
i say to myself okay this is not an 18
to 25 year old crowd
so i'm going to make a general statement
here that i think is going to land for a
lot of us
for a lot of us we lived in the business
life
let alone life prior to this device
existing
and really established the way we worked
the way we thought
the way things worked this is truly
truly the remote control of society it
just is
we can sit here and have an hour debate
of do you like that are you mad at
technology did you like how it used to
be that's fine that's a different
conversation
we're here under the context of business
and
the individuals whether running for
office
whether raising money for nonprofits and
the organizations
whether b2b how many people here are b2b
raise your hands just like get a sense
prop statics wow quite a bit so this
excites me
the great misstep of b2b 2020
marketing 2021 marketing is not
understanding that everybody that just
raised their hands
in my opinion one man's point of view
need to be putting out
five to 15 pieces of creative on
linkedin
a day a day excuse me for one second
jim you put out uh you put five or 15
pieces out a day don't you jim
um at least at least jim
and and and when you understand those
pieces of content whether a written word
a white
as big as a white paper because you
spent a month on it or as little as
a sentence when you understand how to
run media
on linkedin against the job
descriptions or job titles of the
decision makers
or my favorite one because i'm in 401
land not 101 land at this point in my
career
to put in front of the influencers of
the decision makers
to sign up for your sas product let you
be the service provider
let you consult when people start
understanding that
this group understands that being great
at linkedin pictures videos written
words
slideshares decks and running media on
linkedin
is more important than knowing how to
balance your
payroll and pay your taxes when people
in this room when this world
understands what i'm saying is true it
changes every behavior
it changes every behavior if i run every
one of the companies that just ran
raise their hands if i run those
i do things that go against that
religion let me give you a great example
let's talk about this
this is a shockingly bad use of my time
this right now if i'm being practical
the value of my time my business is what
i'm doing this is not good roi i have a
lot i have a warm spot for ink
i love entrepreneurs i'm a human but the
real reason
i'm doing this is because i'm going to
get content out of it
literally the reason i want to go to q a
is michelle
or brent or olaf are going to ask me a
question which is going to require me to
go more narrow
and more detailed on somewhere where i
wouldn't naturally go
myself which i can then strip the audio
or the video from this and then
reproduce it post produce it with copy
and distribute it whether i want to
distribute it on linkedin
or on a facebook i mean you know that is
the incredible incredible things you
know and so
i think you know it's it's a huge
i want to see what carol said carol i
love q a carol i saw you wrote something
can you can you read this and we can jam
on it
yes it's carol culhane um and
i'm i'm eating my lunch which is why i
am no worries
but i when it was at 15 a day i just
thought oh no
there's one person in a sort of our
group cluster and
she's on there at least twice a day
and we just tune her out
um and so i'm i'm shocked that you would
recommend that
i talk about it i might post once a
month
and i like what i put up it's quality
i like the responses i get but 15 a day
let's talk about it so let's talk about
it so
first of all i i noticed i listened very
carefully you said a word quality
you're judging the quality carol about
your own self you're grading your own
homework
right also on the other side you and
your colleagues
are judging this individual and that is
a very small focus group of the entire
prospective group number three you might
be 100 right
let everybody be reminded here that the
variable of success
is the creative so if this creative from
this colleague is poor
self-centered selfish not bringing value
i that could also very much make sense
to me why
it's being tuned out now let's take a
step back you
once a month this colleague twice a day
are posting
organically and it's hitting
a lot of the same people when i talk
about everybody's businesses here and i
say 15 a day
i talk about media planning so i want
you to make a video
that might be targeting a certain state
a specific organization a specific
problem
narrow to one of the business that
you're trying to target
may have when you make that video of
like hey
i'll give you an example i'll i'll jam
with you carol hey guys it's carol
are you an accountant that's the first
thing you say well good news carol
we've spent 88 or 400 on linkedin
only against people who are accountants
so as you can see where i'm about to go
and i think some people are going to
start
picking up the pieces of where i go with
that master headline
you're making a piece of content just
for accountants and why you
or your organization is valuable to them
and then you may be done with that video
or that written article or the audio
clip that you wanted to distribute
and then you may restart and make
another video
and say hey for all the real estate
agents let's talk about what's going up
so now all of a sudden you can see how
you can get to 15
very easily because you might be saying
the same thing slightly different
to 15 different groups of people
so i always say that this is about
basking robins
instead of what i think everybody in the
world is doing which is they're selling
vanilla
when you're making one message for
everyone you're only going to hit a very
small group of people
when you understand how the internet's
structured and these platforms are
structured you realize
that you don't have to waste money or
time and effort to distribute messages
that don't necessarily hit the mark for
the person that's on the other end of it
and then to your point without knowing
anything um about the individual that
you guys are razzing
you know she or he may not be putting
out content i think one of the biggest
things for everyone here
my career and the other things that i've
seen that have worked are predicated on
putting out content that brings value to
the audience
it's not a sales call it's not a right
what i call a right hook
it's a jab i'm trying to build brand and
intrigue
and relevance which then creates
consideration to do something with me
not trying to close somebody on my
process or they should
hire me immediately on the first thing
they see in their feed
so that that's where some of the 15
comes from and then by the way
you know there's there's also taking a
video and posting it and then stripping
the audio out of it and posting it
because some people like audio
and then transcribing the written word
you know because you you've realized
this all
i mean i'm going to very advanced places
and i'm coming back down
if if everybody here knew that they
could hire somebody from fiverr
and pay them five dollars you know to
transcribe a video
all of a sudden like oh i can like
there's a stunning
misunderstanding and lack of education
of the production and distribution of
internet content today
and i come here today openhearted hoping
that i can get one of you
to take this way more seriously because
the financial impacts
are extraordinary they really are when
you really understand brand and sales
in these environments so makes sense
cindy it's
carol excuse me which is why i wanted to
call you in here because
she's going organic hitting the same
people over and over with that organic
eventually the algorithm will stop
showing that to hurt you
if you stop engaging with it if you and
your colleagues enjoy looking at it and
then making fun of it well then
linkedin's going to think you like it so
they can keep showing it to you
so it's that's kind of how it works
in a little detail carol makes sense yes
thank you and i think team for everybody
here real quick b to c
companies in here raise your hands so
for the
hands that just went up as you can
imagine for you 15
becomes you know entry level because
b2b linkedin is a dream b2c
facebook twitter instagram you can
imagine these 15 become 113.
now i don't want to overwhelm you with
the number back to carol's point
you know if you're sitting here eating
your sandwich offline or salad and
you're once a month and i'm coming in
here with all this energy 15 a day or
you're dead
you know it's listen there's nothing
nobody's going out of business if they
don't do this properly
i really i don't believe overnight but i
will promise all of you and it's very
clear in the data
you're losing market share by not this
is not about you're going out of
business this is
hey give 20 hours of your mind time
nobody got to this call by not putting
in real work ethic
and no matter where you are in your
career isn't it worth getting 20 hours
of education on this
with yourself on google and youtube it's
not about paying anybody this is about
getting your hands dirty learning at
very low costs
about what it takes to be a good
communicator on the internet
because it's it's wildly playing out
from netflix to paluton to
every election like the mapping of the
math is very clear
there is an incredible upside to buying
attention at a better price
it worked in radio it worked in
television it worked in cable it worked
in early internet
i'll give you an example i built my
daddy's wine shop the thing i'm known
for from a lot of people
when we had no money i took it from a
three to a 65 million dollar business
with no money because i knew that google
adwords
were really cheap nobody was buying them
i was the first person to buy all the
wine terms
they were five cents a click and
because nobody knew i was able to build
a very big company
meanwhile while i was doing that a
gentleman by name of jeff bezos
had a lot of capital had a lot of talent
and he became by far amazon amazon was
google adwords biggest ad spender for
the first six years of that platform
stick with me here now by a 30x
multiplier against ebay which was number
two
that organization figured out the
attention was so underpriced on google
search
that they bet the house on it and used
many things but that
move is a foundational brick to why
amazon
is a company that eventually will have
to probably be broken up by the
government
because of their dominance there is
nothing more valuable my friends
than you being able to get the attention
of the person that makes the decision
to give you money right i mean it's
you know how one does that i think about
all of the
golfing and steak dinners and booths you
buy at conferences and direct mail and
print
and then i think about the last seven
years of people doing some social media
but them doing it with their niece or a
come by lately person that says they
knew how to do it because most business
owners didn't know how to judge it and
so i understand why we sit here today in
2021
with people confused of is this
important or not is it good or not
does it do anything for my business or
not but i would i would leave with this
and i'll go into the next questions
hey andrea kaelin feel free to navigate
me by calling on someone
the roi of a basketball for gary
vaynerchuk is about a negative 150 000
at this point given the injuries that
i've incurred in last five years of two
torn meniscus and a broken foot
the roi of a basketball for lebron james
is going to be north of a billion
dollars
when that gentleman goes through his
life
this is about knowing how to use the
tool
but the roi is clearly there and i i
want to motivate
people to take a second third fifth
ninth look
at the content and media ecosystem for
your businesses
because i see it work every day of the
week every day of the week
gary there's an interesting question
from corey cory i don't know if you want
to
maybe address your question about
measurement
sure hey gary it's corey from jnj
uh one of the questions i have is just
if you think about the
infinite number of things that you can
measure track of the volume of data i'm
just curious
like what is the if you had to bring it
down to one metric that really matters
like what would you
measure as a leading indicator for
whether or not you're being successful
in the space
i only measure sales and obviously as
you know because i work with fortune 500
cpg brands
everything that that world does does not
measure sales which is why i'm so happy
about amazon and direct to consumer
because it's going to bring that dna
into the j and js of the world
as a leading indicator that you're on
the right path what we do is we do
isolated media spends and literally show
clean and clean i'm literally working on
this in real time i'm going to show
clean and clear that
in chicago at walgreens we're selling
more stuff
it took us getting the clean and clear
team to allow us to make
thousands of pieces of creative with
micro media spends
so that you can actually measure because
you're isolating
an indicator is qualitative feedback
the number one thing that has shown me
actual business results more than clicks
follows
shares is real humans saying things
about the product
or service that not only leads to an
indicator but usually
leads to iteration of the creative or
the product and service
to fulfill the real humans needs aka
insights from the written words of
people when you run the ads
so for example back to the carol example
if she gets 29 comments from those real
estate agents if she reads that
and sees an inspiration or an
observation or gets positive sentiment
from there
it's been a real indicator for business
success but i suffocate the media and
the creative
you live in a world where because media
and creative are separate and nobody
wants to be accountable
every every agency that works with j j
doesn't want to be accountable
which is why there's no measurement we
come in and want to be very
accountable and so we suffocate media
and creative to prove
sales lift at steel shelves in retail
yeah of course and what did you post
there you have tracer.tech
this was a company that we incubated
internally we just took it out of our
ecosystem you should definitely
inquiry um i know that sanofi is a
client of theirs it's part of the vayner
x family
they're a sas uh data analytics uh
almost like data rama 3.0 of really
measuring
the true indication of how to measure
creative for a company as global as you
with so many other things that you'll be
activating at the same time
so it might be worth you getting at
least a little demo with them
charlie you you might want to share your
your question about how to
how and when do you jump on new uh new
formats that are coming out in your
in the b2c world maybe charlie's not
he's not here on mute how's that
there we go charlie fantastic no worries
brother
there's an explosion i'm charlie hart
i'm with uh ledvance better known as
sylvania that's the brand we
we sell in the b2c series and
my question is there's an explosion of
platforms yes
you can interface with cast consumers
over
what appears to be a myriad of different
platforms the last one that came to my
attention was parlor correct how do you
when do you know when you need to jump
on you just jump on as soon as you can
is it
splash paint on everyone or what i'm a
big fan that this is all about consumer
insights charlie and so
for me parlor is the greatest indication
of how to understand the psyche
of conservative point of view americans
right now
and so i'm on it watching and listening
and learning
um as a human uh but to be frank as a
businessman
um and so i believe that people think of
these platforms as i have to go on there
and
sell make money this has to be a worth
my time
to me going on these platforms early the
worth my time is getting
early indications of the psychology and
the anthropology of how humans think
which then i factor into how i create
and do
so i don't see how in any shape or form
when everybody here is selling to at
least 50 percent of humans that think
that way
that parlor does why that's not a good
use of two hours even if you're the most
liberal left person in this room when
you put on your business
hat the insights are very important and
so
but you also have to know the demo right
i know that that skews
dramatically far right to middle right
and that's the psyche and why they're
there i know that tick tock was
young girls first now it's at 30 and 40
year olds all of a sudden they hit the
radar here
the reason when i saw so many you know
all i'm doing is listening
all the time the reason i asked how many
people are here are b2b and i see 80
of the hands go up now all of a sudden
i'm going to talk a lot about linkedin
because i want to bring as much value to
this audience right now when i'm with
you
so i think it's context distribution
things of that nature you got to know
who you're selling to what you're
selling
and then there's you know so if you're a
consumer product you have to have a
massive facebook and instagram
you know strategy and execution because
it consumes
it takes up so many people's hours of
mine time
it's like i mean facebook and instagram
combined is like running commercials on
mash in the 80s everyone's seeing it if
you're good at it
you know and so that's how i think about
that charlie i think it's a i think
for everybody here if you have ambition
if you have professional ambition
every one of these things that pop up
are worth five hours of your time
if you're a private person create a fake
account make it about your business not
you
create a fake person i don't care but
learn what people are doing on it and
how they're thinking
when they're in that room because once
you understand
that charlie is a different person when
he's going through his linkedin than he
is when he's going through his facebook
that once you understand that you're
going to put out different videos and
pictures on those platforms
this is real creative strategy and
that's something that a lot of people
miss the mark on as well
everybody just wants to use all these
platforms as distribution charlie
everybody's looking for efficiencies hey
gary can i just make one video and post
it everywhere no you cannot
do you act the same way with your
grandchildren that you act with your
boss
that you do with your girlfriends on
your 50th anniversary meet up in las
vegas no you have different
angles to your personality why would you
put
the same video on tick tock that you're
going to put on linkedin you couldn't be
more different
with the potential people that are going
to be consuming that you have to make
your product service
and what you're trying to accomplish
completely contextually different in
those environments
but people people value
scale and lower co right versus
relevance i mean corey back to your
world this is my biggest problem with
big corporations
they value potential reach over actual
consumer relevance
which is why you get one commercial and
you get one big media spend
and then you get a little bit of
[ __ ] matching luggage for digital
that's usually done on programmatic
garbage inventory
and you call it a day and then
everybody's trying to figure out why
we're losing market share
it's because we're not consumer-centric
putting the same video on linkedin
twitter and facebook is not being
consumer-friendly it's being efficient
for you on distribution but you're
actually wasting your time more than
you're winning
because you're not getting to anybody
back to the vanilla analogy that i told
carol because nobody gives a [ __ ] the
reason for that though
is they're trying to be brand
consistency right so they're doing the
same thing across multiple platforms
where you're consistent across your
brand
but that's that's a that's a thing
that's taught at business school
and and taught at university it doesn't
play out to real humans
nobody walks around and talks about
brand consistency nobody
no but that promise of the brand needs
to be relevant in whatever
yes but think about it if i said to
everybody right now everybody write down
what nike means to them
everybody write down what coca-cola
means from you're going to get different
answers there may be some thematics
but you're going to get different
answers and until we as companies
understand that
that it's more about relevance this
brand consistency that big companies
play on
is is academia it's it's corporation
talk
it's politics it it doesn't manifest in
true practicality on the consumer level
okay think about even back to the b2b
people what you might say to the actual
cfo or cio
may be very different than somebody you
would say two layers down if you're a
salesperson in here
and you have to replicate that in the
content that may inspire them to bring
the awareness to the decision maker
context it's incredibly important it's
how you get to 15 pieces of content
if you're religious about context you
now understand 15.
if you're if you're thinking about
efficiencies for distribution
you think in one piece of content
i had a question if i can please um
just it was just on content but actually
before i asked a question my 17 year old
daughter was walking by my office
and said is that garyvee online and i
honestly
did not i mean i did look you up she
goes i follow him on tick tock
i watch the youtube videos and uh so i'm
clearly out of touch but you're not
about to touch it i i
what's your name my friend cause i can't
see basically stan from uh from toronto
thank you my friend stan what you just
did
is the greatest thing that any teacher
ever wants which is you just gave
affirmation to everything i've just been
talking about my ability
to have 17 year old girls in toronto
know who i am and 64 year old
business men and women on linkedin in
chicago like
i am cross platform and what i put out
on tick tock
as you can imagine let me say hi what's
her name she's like she's like wow
hello hi
thanks for listening to my content i
appreciate it yeah thank you
what do you like about his content um
honestly i love
how like passionate you feel about your
work just like when you talk
when you talk is on super cool and it's
inspiring so thank you
thank you it's really nice to meet you
thank you you too thank you
but as everybody can imagine what i'm
putting out on tick tock
to bring that inspiration that might be
talking about the pressure of parents
worrying about grades or hey you're 17
i promise you as a 45 year old you're
way younger than you think you don't
have to have life figured out
or you know hey try a lot of different
things
because the world's going to change a
lot nobody thought that esports
playing video games 20 years was good it
was a good idea now those people make
tens of millions of dollars there's a
lot of parents
that are upset that they you know kurt
i'll never be able to until i buy the
jets curt i won't be able to figure out
how to that's my goal i got to buy the
jets to figure that one out but stan
so my question is on content like just
this morning my my head of
uh digital marketing who's an engineer
saying hey you gotta you gotta like all
the stuff we're doing on linkedin you
gotta amplify it
i guess i mean this is an eye-opening to
me is um
i guess i'm a content i i feel like it's
the head of the company that
if i'm putting out content it should be
of different or higher quality and
does that make me a content snob or i
should am i am i looking at it
differently i guess the question is that
as a head of an organization the content
that we're putting out if you're putting
out 10 or 15 pieces of content it's
going to be really hard
for it to all be good unless someone's
doing it for you but
how should we view that or i guess very
differently
look we do this at vaynerx right our
company puts out a lot of content and i
put out
a lot of content and they're very
different i um kailyn and andrea here
who deal with a lot of our business uh
doris content is just create is just con
is is a video of anything that you see
on a social network
that's content a video a picture a
written word
you know that's content it's just it's a
print ad a billboard
a radio ad a jingle like anything that's
consumed um stan back to you
i would argue that some of the content
that i put out actually
makes it hard for andrea and kalyn to
get get our company to get business
because i curse because i've got a
different edge and sometimes a very
conservative company that really wants
to work with vaynermedia may be
turned off by a founder that's a little
too jersey i would also argue
that because i'm authentic and i'm
passionate and it's not coming from a
bad place
that there's a lot of people that find
that refreshing and want to work
i think the content you need to put out
is the content that's true to you
you know the truth of the energy of the
intent and truth
always over performs whether you're very
conservative very
very silly very you know your sense of
humor is your strength not your weakness
this whole notion of suit and tie look
professional it's dying by the second
by the second and we need to recognize
that now one may think that's bad
and i understand that i genuinely do i
just am not in the business of judging
society i'm in the business
of reacting to society and i think a lot
of people get caught up in that
and i think your company should be
putting out a certain piece of content
and different kinds of content
and i think you should be putting out
content you being an avid fisherman or
loving hockey or being into
bourbon or liking golf maybe the
connection point in that one video or in
that one
article that leads to somebody
considering to do something with you
thank you you're welcome thank you gary
there's an
interesting question that might kind of
piggyback off on that theme that comes
from
and i apologize i might um mispronounce
this rubok wealth team
talking about how do they make sure that
they're putting out content that can be
picked up by the media
meaning pr um that takes being
pr savvy you know understanding what p
understanding that pr is selfish they're
not in the business of
amplifying your business they're in in
the business
of getting people to view things that's
why we all get mad at
the news for being sensationalism the
problem is they were forced into it as a
business because that's what we react to
we like rubber necking
unfortunately it's the human spirit you
know it is what it is
i think you need to be clever you need
to you need to understand
you know a different take i think being
very culturally relevant this is why i
like everybody producing content
because it's going to teach you about
what's going on um
i love craig earlier for bringing up
parlor right
maybe you put out like a post on yeah
for example if i wanted press
i would immediately write a linkedin
post right now
saying why i'm considering parlor and
what i see
there i guarantee you get somebody
reaching out to you wanting to be in an
article because they all want to write
about it because it's a polarizing thing
right now
right so like you know i think i think
understanding that the media is selfish
they're not in the business to be your
publicist is the biggest mindset that i
see people not understanding
and so that's you need to bring them
value not them they're not there for you
so it's a mindset of what you want to
talk about and what you put out there
there's a an interesting question from
sean
beyer um they're b2c company and they're
interested
in uh let's get shown here yeah
hi um yeah we're a beautiful c company
so
we have consumer services uh spa
services
but then we also uh manufacture products
uh that are sold
on both sides and wholesalers yeah i
love it what's that you're on both ends
b2b and bbc yeah so we uh
my question is is we're really trying to
ramp up the amount of content marketing
that we're doing
across multiple channels but we
obviously still have a very large paid
digital
uh budget um what are your thoughts on
how to
determine how do you how do you set your
budgets
for resources and time uh for that
yep i am far more allocated to content
creation than media amplification than
almost
anything or anyone i've ever seen in a
world of 80 20
and i don't know if you're even more
extreme because big companies will go 80
20.
for everybody to catch up what we're
saying 80 of the money that you do for
marketing is spent for
placing the ads amplifying it media
spending
um you know in the old days it was 80 of
the money was
to buy the print slot and then 20 was to
make the ad
80 was to buy the television and 20 was
to make the commercial
80 is to buy the facebook ads and the
google ads and 20
you know i'm i'm more of a you're not
you may be stunned by this i'm a 60 40
content guy
which is like insanity for most business
people but i just know the creative is
the variable and i'm also extremely good
at understanding underpriced media right
like
so when you do you're great at the media
planning and spending when you know how
to go long tail facebook when you know
that tick tock is grossly underpriced
when you know your [ __ ]
you're able to pour more because i know
the creative is the variable of success
now on the extreme of extremes i don't
even really recommend it
but i think you have to be somewhere in
the 70 30
70 media 30 creative do you have a sense
of where you're at right now oh
yeah it's probably like ninety five five
yeah yeah
yeah that's it that's the you know
that's knowing that you're a little bit
deeper
and some of the like that's the big
unlock oh okay and then by the way you
gotta really audit that 90 like what are
you doing because
what where i help a lot of people is
when that 90
is bad at what it does you can imagine
when you take it to 70 and it's better
than the 90
and the money goes into great creative
now you're getting into a real game
yeah and that's honestly so many people
are just cac
they're they're metrics oriented not
business oriented
right you got a good price on our
impressions or they might be too
business oriented gary
don't talk to me i'm acquiring customers
for 200 210
and i'm making enough profit on that and
i'm like cool but isn't acquiring
customers for 130 better
and wouldn't you be willing to go to 260
for a little while to find the thing
that gets you to 130.
so what i've come to learn my friend is
i just can't believe how many people are
not business oriented when they talk
about marketing
they either don't understand it or they
don't hold it accountable to business
i grew up in a family liquor store
business where we were immigrants from
the soviet union every dollar i spent
sasha vaynerchuk really cared if i did
good or not with it so my marketing
training was only business oriented not
going to brand school or getting brought
up in procter and gamble or
or you know you see where i'm going and
but i'm a brander i'm a marketer i'm not
a salesman
and i think too many people give up on
branding and marketing
because they're really sales people and
they want to know what every single
penny does for them right now
and that's why i always beat them
they're even though my energy looks like
i'm the
hair the rabbit my actions are very
tortoise
thoughtful insights slow learn poor
lighter fluid on what works
my excitement for my model is high
that's what you're feeling right now
but i'm very slow and calculated
as a matter of fact i'm building a
consumer i'm building a business right
now
and i've been taking the last 11 years
running vaynermedia to build this
bricks and the steel for the business
i'm gonna build which is i'm building
this entire marketing company
just to buy businesses the reason i
started the sasha group
the small business version of the
vaynermedia was a
truthfully be told because i enjoy these
businesses a little bit more
you know really matters when you do good
work for a small business
you can like you know people cry with
when they talk to me you know
immigrant moms hug me like fun stuff um
but i also did it because i don't know
what i'm gonna buy you know i might buy
a 47
chain pizza shop in canada back to our
friend in toronto
and i want to be great at marketing in
calgary like i
this is very calculated for me and i
want it to be for all of you
because i think social media or
marketing gets a bad name it is the
the internet commoditizes everything but
the ability to communicate
all of your businesses will continue to
get pressured by the internet's
infrastructure
it was the limo services it was the
hotel things if you're in real estate
zillow's coming after you
like everything's going to continue to
happen this way and
you know the networks didn't see netflix
coming
right like the car companies didn't see
tesla technology and the internet is
going to change
everything and if you don't know how to
communicate on it
you're not going to have a protection
mechanism to when it comes for your
business
it's like a title it's like a huge wave
either everybody here realizes
hopefully this is the serendipitous
moment that you decide to build a great
surfboard
or that wave is going to smash you in
the face
gary jim schleckster has a question
about where there are
media bargains today uh
jim jimmy where are you there you are
brother so jim where's your target it
i mean tick tock is by far the one okay
so we're b2b
management consulting ceo advisory work
we spend a lot of time on linkedin
variety of flavors in linkedin do you
spend a lot of media money on linkedin
um not a ton we're more we
i wouldn't know i wouldn't say we're
your ratio on content but we a lot of
video
but you're getting it from the or you're
putting it out because linkedin also
gives you good organic reach so you're
you're satisfied which makes sense to me
jim you're satisfied on
making the content and putting it out
organically not doing what i want which
is
you pick four target clients and you
make i'll give you an example i want
everybody to hear this
jim actually let's play what would be a
company that you would love to be doing
business with like you wish they
hired you or used your service you know
a
200 million dollar valve manufacturer
milwaukee would be an awesome client for
us so if you're looking random but
beautiful no i love this if you and i
became partners tomorrow i'd say brother
get who here can get me the data on
every company in america that looks like
that
then that come that would come then i
would go on linkedin me
or my whoever i brought over and we
would look at which companies are
registered that are big enough
that have enough employees on there that
we can target the employees of
you got to do an employee account
because they don't do revenue correct
so right so you got to look at those
things once
that happens we target those companies
and we make content that looks like this
hey does your cfo or who's the decision
maker your head of procurement cio cfo
whose ceo decides in in your world
yeah beautiful so i would produce
content that literally looked like this
hey does your ceo know that she or he is
losing
i you know i don't know your value prop
but i'm sure there's six of them
if you had dinner with asea right i
would make
those six value props i would make six
different ways written word video or now
i have 36 pieces of content
that we're targeting against the
employees of one company with the hope
that one of them
forwards it got it influenced the
influencer
yeah got it see where i'm going we gotta
get somebody to put the scope bottle on
the desk
that's exactly right that's exactly
right you know and when you
or when you're broad enough and you know
it's the cia anybody here have an
interesting
job title that is the decision maker
like chief procurement
cio anybody here have anything that's
not ceo
you can unmute just trying to give
another analogy i'll give you
we have a client that sells outsourced
business services
so it would be like manager of
outsourcing or call center manager or
something like that
and sometimes procurement sometimes vpa
procurements it could be
any of those star yeah exactly like just
the sheer technicality that you can get
into a linkedin environment
and again carol back to you right notice
how i just talked about one company
36 pieces of content because there's six
value props
you want to say it six different ways
because you don't know if it's the video
the written word the picture
right and you know and so i mean this is
real stuff everyone
i'm telling you this is real stuff we
have a a glass manufacturer that wants
the industry to use glasses
that is blown away by what's been going
on in the first couple months with us we
have we
work right they have so much challenges
with co-working and this is
like but we're blowing b2b companies
away with our work
in linkedin and by the way facebook has
been proven to be an incredibly
effective
b2b channel as well when you plan the
media on certain targeting if you know a
certain thing like
universities there's a lot of different
but you know obviously this all goes on
what you can target
and then once you know what you're
targeting you know what you're going to
say
but um jim i think you've got to really
rev up the capabilities whether
internally or externally around media
spend
on linkedin okay now most media
we do retargeting sponsor content that
kind of stuff but fair enough
sponsorship
we're missing a ton of tricks a bunch of
content i would get out of it just makes
you feel good that a lot of people saw
it but they're not the people that you
want
retargeting i love anybody that's come
to your website keep pounding them until
they give up
but we're prospecting where the content
really knows who's seeing it
got it yep it goes back it goes back to
stan's daughter right i know
17 year olds are seeing my tick tocks
you can imagine how that affects what
i'm saying
versus what i'm saying to 58 you know
i'm i'll give you one as a human i'm
passionate that people in their 50s and
60s are delusional about how much life
they have left ahead of them
but society has convinced them that they
don't so when i make a video
to talk to those individuals and i'm
running that on facebook 55
to 75 year olds that are entrepreneurs
or executives
i may curse less the answers i do i may
talk about different analogies i may
make a joke about razzing about
hey you don't want your daughter making
fun of you let's show her you know like
everything that comes out of my mouth is
different
i i did it meta in here right i asked
you know i'm bringing it up again but i
want everybody to really hear me
once i understood how b to b this is
look how much linkedin i'm talking if
this was b2c i'd be talking about other
stuff in this time
context
gary robin whalen has a question about
auto-generated content robin are you
yeah a little bit more about that hey hi
gary i
am i'm a i run an ad agency social media
agency in toronto
very nice um and we are i'm totally
hearing you about how important creative
is and i would put it when you look at
media and you look at the offer and you
would look at creative i would put
creative in terms of the
the element that drives the most impact
so
[Applause]
sorry one of the things that
um bothers me the most is
auto-generated creative right and what
i'm seeing in the industry where there's
clients are wanting to spend less in the
development of the idea
because they can get pretty creative
through google display network or
whatever my thoughts are it's a nice
thing to have two to three percent of
your energy on but big companies and
clients love it because they think
they're saving money but they don't
realize they're not getting the business
results they want
yeah and because they're scoring on
costs not on long-term business results
they think it's a good thing but it's a
bad thing oh okay
i totally agree i just always wondered
if there's a different perspective out
there
you know there's different perspectives
when somebody's
job in a big company for marketing is to
drive down the cost of creative
and that's their kpi and their boss said
to them if you cut this by 20
i'll give you a bonus of 10 and they go
and do it
and that's because they play defense and
they're not consumer-centric
and they're building their business in a
excel sheet and
as a cfo not as a ceo that's who likes
it
amen no argument here thanks for that
kelvin johnson you have a question about
a brainstorming process that's going to
lead to the best content you want to
fill us in a little bit more on that
yeah you mentioned i like your ratio you
mentioned that kind you're you over
index on content versus the the media
spin
and just what what tactics tools
resources do you really have a great
story a great narrative is super
important
how can people get better and what's
been your secret sauce to continuously
produce that great content
kelvin i'm going to give you a crazy off
speed pitch you ready
the complete most important ingredient
to the question that you just asked
is hr it's culture
the only way you get great ideas is if
people feel
safe to say them out loud the reason
most
organizations and companies struggle
with good ideas is there's usually
somebody in the room
that is the killer of ideas imposing his
or her
political will against the rest of the
crew
humility kindness curiosity
are the elements to unlock what you're
asking and unless you have a culture of
that
if you if you the boss are like i don't
like that and you make people feel
scared
to throw things that you're dead if
there's somebody ahead of your creative
and she or he wields their political
clout and justify their being
based on judging everybody else's ideas
you're dead
this is a cultural execution
and that is why i think vayner's world
exploded
because we focused on that we thought
that was the seed and now we're getting
the dividends of it because people feel
safe
on the first day to throw something
against the wall and not have some
senior creative
make them feel little
and the follow up with that real quick
any like routines that you do personally
or walks or maybe yep yep i put out all
the content
i have a thought i make it got it people
demonize quality
people demonize quantity when it is the
singular unlock
of an internet infrastructure and that's
why everyone's struggling
for 50 years it was subjective quality
conversation mad men era
you know bosses being bosses and then
the internet came along
where it would value you if you could
put out a lot of things because it would
give you feedback loops that were clean
data
i don't suppress my ideas i don't need
to take a walk or exercise
or meditate or drink tea when i feel
safe
and put it out that is all that
those are band-aids to bad human
behavior
i like that one
gary i think we might have one time for
one more question so you got to go at
135 but there's a question from boris
who comes from the charitable sector and
fundraising
sector boris maybe you want to fill us
in yeah for sure
thanks it's great to to listen to you
gary look um
i typically meet with philanthropists
like successful entrepreneurs basically
that have made enough money that they
can make a gift
at the end of the year ten thousand
fifty thousand dollars
and and i ask very personally you know i
kind of pitched the the organization the
impact we're having
it's very high touch and all that is out
the window with uh
with the pandemic right i wonder if you
have any insights on
on how to tell the you know sort of
invite people who make significant
philanthropic gifts
in a different way than just the
high-touch relation
well first of all boris and i've been
doing it because you know i i'm on
i'm on charity water and pencil promise
and i'm on the board and a big driver
i converted those drinks and cocktail
hours into this
yeah and then back to the point of this
whole talk and
after we do this i asked sometimes
prospective people if they would allow
me
to chop up the video and use it as
content that i put out on linkedin and
target
high net worth individuals i
only live in a world where i want every
minute of my life to be recorded
so that i can then post produce it for
my ambitions
yeah that's cool it is cool
it's very efficient right you get four
people together you do your spiel it's a
good thing there's a moment
but now you got your spiel on film and
now and if you get the permission for
those four and you may or may not
because given the nature of who those
kind of people are
but guess what you might not even need
them because it might just be what you
said
is what you're chopping mm-hmm i don't
need any of you all
for my content here because i can just
use my part of it
yeah that's cool i hope everybody
enjoyed this and got some value out of
it i wish all of you a really healthy
and awesome holiday
thank you so much for your time thank
you gary
thank you so much thank you for saying
that thanks awesome gary thanks
i appreciate that jim bye everyone thank
you thank you gary thank you very much
thank you it's very good thanks everyone
and if there's anything we can do to
help you if you're looking for talent
if you're you know if you have other
questions that you just thought of
right now feel free i'm going to put my
name in the chat
um as well and i'd be happy to um to
have gary respond to anything else that
you might think of
even you know throughout this summit
that you're uh so lucky to be attending
andrea thank you so much thank you
looking good yeah thanks for helping us
set this up andrew it's really awesome
thank you oh well thank you thanks for
all the the participation that's what
makes this
uh makes it hopefully more practical
and uh gives you a little bit of
inspiration on the side you guys are
great
great session a lot of homework
don't we all
don't we all i'm just trying to keep up
with gary
my god thank you andrea all right thanks
everybody have a great summit
youtube what's up it's garyvee first of
all thank you so much i hope you're
doing super well during these
times uh i also want to ask you please
subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls
more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you